[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 6 mars bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tour
d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition aller à la gare à vélo et le
stationner dans un lieu sécurisé
principe des consignes des ligues au qui
fleurissent en ile-de-france après saint
quentin en yvelines
un nouvel espace est en service depuis
la mi-février en gare de versailles rive
gauche
inauguration ce mardi matin en présence
de la présidente de région valérie
pécresse
comment renforcer la dynamique des
territoires a grillé robin en
ile-de-france questions soulevées demain
lors d'un séminaire à villepreux il a
pour but de montrer que la présence de
terres agricoles autour de grandes
métropoles est un facteur d'attractivité
invités de ce journal alexandre ruesch
exploitants à bailly membres de
l'association organisatrice de cet
événement
et puis le portrait de la semaine est
consacrée à romain lucas ce jeune chef
gérant d'un établissement à versailles
propose une cuisine semi gastronomique
ils misent ses recettes sur des produits
frais et bio locaux le drame hier lundi
attrape une jeune automobiliste d'une
vingtaine d'années est décédé après une
collision avec un bus l'accident s'est
produit sur la d 9 112 à proximité de
l'île de loisirs vers 15h30 la victime
qui se serait déporté sur la voie
opposée a percuté le véhicule du réseau
stibus de face elle est morte sous le
choc est la passagère de la voiture a
été transporté en urgence dans un état
grave à l'hôpital percy à clamart huit
passagers du bus ont été blessés
légèrement
c'est un dossier sur la table depuis
plus de 20 ans la nouvelle ère des 30 à
plaisir a été inauguré ce matin en
présence de la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse axe souvent saturée
entre elancourt et plaisir la route
départementale a été doublée et
réaménagé trois ans de travaux ont été
nécessaires un chantier chiffré à 87,5
millions d'euros 33 millions financés
par l'île de france 54 par le
département des yvelines propos
collectées sur place par patrick jacques
de dixmude et quentin le frère
c'est la base même d'une femme à qui et
les fondamentaux pour que notre ville
puisse avoir des aspirations encore
supplémentaires dans un développement à
la fois commercial économique et un
cadre de vie parce que ça apporte
effectivement un grand confort à notre
ville
on aura beau et noble outillage
d'ailleurs on en a déjà beaucoup moi
puisque le matin dans le centre-ville on
se rend compte que déjà c'est beaucoup
plus fluide
donc ça veut dire que sur dans tous les
domaines qui nous importe c'est quelque
chose qui est véritablement il réussit
problème de la grande couronne et
problème du nombre plage de la
francilienne
nous sommes le seul département où elle
ne passe pas donc les voitures qui
empruntent la francilienne venant du sud
venant du nord se déverse sur nos
voiries et en particulier sur nos
voiries nord-sud et se déversant un créé
des embouteillages et donc nous oblige à
élargir les voies et à faire des
infrastructures qui ne sont pas des
infrastructures classiques de route
départementale des travaux doivent être
encore réalisé sur la rd 30 d'ici
l'année prochaine la création d'une
passerelle piétons cyclistes est la
finalisation d'un bassin de stockage des
eaux pluviales ainsi que la réalisation
et d'aménagement paysager nous
reviendrons plus longuement sur cette
inauguration
dans notre édition de demain mercredi
elle est en service depuis le 19 février
c'est la consigne à vélo de la gare
versailles satory gauche elle permet à
chacun de l'itie en toute sécurité son
deux roues avant de prendre le train
l inauguration officielle se dérouler ce
mardi matin en présence d'élus locaux où
wilfrid réchy et nicolas kirillovitch
128 places de stationnement réservées
exclusivement aux vélos en garde
versailles château rive gauche les
usagers adeptes du deux roues peuvent
dorénavant prendre sereinement leur
train grâce à vélib ou c'est sûr que
c'est pas une station v ligocki va
améliorer la régularité des trains mais
néanmoins il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous disent ok on comprend vous avez des
problèmes sur les trains mais au moins
est ce que moi je peux garé mon vélo à
la gare de façon sécurisée et donc c'est
très important aussi de s'occuper de ce
premier de ce dernier kilomètre 5800
places de stationnement ont déjà été
créés à travers l'île de france
vingt mille seront disponibles d'ici
2020 région et sncf se partagent le
financement de 120 mille euros ont été
nécessaires pour cet espace dans la cité
royale ile-de-france mobilité avec un s
c'est le nouveau nom du syndicat des
transports d'île de france s'occupe dieu
des franciliens du départ de leur
domicile jusqu'à leur arrivée au bureau
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de travailler
sur tous les petits points noirs pour
améliorer la qualité de service aux
voyageurs améliorer la qualité de
service et aussi mettre des espaces de
coworking dans la gare quand on attend
son train c'est pouvoir mettre des
recharges de portable c'est pouvoir
offrir des nouveaux services pour les
usagers le fonctionnement de ce service
est simple l'accès possible 7 jours sur
7 de 5h à 1h30 avec une carte navigo en
cours de validité et moyennant un
abonnement annuel de 20 euros
atout supplémentaire de ce nouvel espace
la présence de seize casiers individuels
pour recharger les vélos électriques
politique pierre bédier s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui devant la presse le
président du conseil départemental a
évoqué différentes actualités du
territoire des yvelines et métropole du
grand paris ligne 18 mais aussi l avenir
de son parti les républicains l'élu
s'est montré offensif envers le
gouvernement les précisions avec ce
sujet de nicolas kirillovitch principale
divergence entre le président du
département des yvelines et le
gouvernement l'avenir de la métropole du
grand paris pierre bédier a répété lors
d'un rendez-vous récemment avec emmanuel
macron qu'il souhaitait une métropole
élargir la région sur un sujet si
complexe il ne crois pas d'ailleurs le
président de la république capable de
faire son choix rapidement
nous avons des enjeux internationaux
à faire le break sites à travers les
jeux olympiques qui sont absolument
considérables et donc il faut réformer
cette région parisienne avec beaucoup de
prudence
il faut avancer d'une main tremblante et
il me semble qu'il faut prendre du temps
non sans lien les annonces sur le grand
paris express sont un scandale d'état
pour pierre bédier
selon lui le gouvernement ne donnerait
pas toutes les informations sur les
dates de livraison et soit une
accélération du calendrier de la ligne
18 pour soutenir le développement du
plateau de saclay dans ce cas-là
suspendons la croissance du plateau de
saclay ou alors et c'est ce que nous
demandons inversion des priorités
d'autres lignes du grand paris express
nous paraissent moins prioritaires et
faisons d'abord cette ligne de saclay
puisqu'il paraît que c'est à saclay que
se prépare l'avenir de la france enfin
la situation des républicains dans les
yvelines le président du département a
reconnu les difficultés de son parti
localement après les échecs aux
élections législatives et le presque
départ depuis du secrétaire
départemental david douillet pour tenter
de relancer la droite yvelinoise il
proposera une présidence collégiale dans
les prochains mois j'aimerais bien
pouvoir former en quelque sorte ces
personnes en formant un ticket pour
faire que notre fédération repartent de
l'avant
jusqu en octobre et l'élection d'une
nouvelle équipe dirigeante et l'air dans
les yvelines c'est sophie primas
sénatrice qui assumera l'intérim à la
tête du parti
un séminaire international au programme
demain mercredi au domaine de
grand'maisons à villepreux les
territoires zagré rubin facteur
d'attractivité des grandes métropoles va
convier toute la matinée
élus représentants agricoles exploitants
professionnels de l'économie verte et
aussi à des chercheurs certaines
certains viennent de l'étranger de
genève milan ou encore montréal bonsoir
alexander resch
bonsoir d'être le président des jeunes
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france est
exploitant à bailly membres de
l'association patrimoniale de la plaine
de versailles et du plateau des halles
us et cette association justement qu'ils
organisent
l'événement un mot peut-être déjà sur
l'association qui regroupe tel et
quelles sont ses missions
cette association elle et elle
représente l'ensemble de la société
civile donc l'un par trois collèges avec
le collège des élus un collège agricole
et un collège de la société civile des
associations et et ensuite la l'intérêt
de ce dynamisme au sein de cette
association c'est de regrouper tout le
monde pour une même cause préserver un
territoire lui donner un intérêt de
qualité de vie un intérêt économique
et qu'est ce qu'on entend par plein de
versailles ça regroupe finalement quelle
étendue du territoire la paix de
versailles
en gros la plaine de versailles
retouches à peu près 5000 hectares il
nous sommes sur environ un territoire
assez découpées qui touche cinq
intercommunalités
donc on va avoir l'occasion de parler de
séminaires lasser les premières
rencontres finance organisée par
l'association plaine de versailles sur
cette thématique de territoires agréés
urbain a une dimension dont on va dire
le métropole
c'est la première fois que nous
travaillons dans ce sens là alors le
séminaire demain concerne justement ces
territoires agréés urbain ces zones qui
concentrent terres urbaines et agricoles
est ce que ça veut dire que
l'ile-de-france est est un territoire à
gré et robin ont finalement l'île de
france regroupe plusieurs territoires
agréés urbain il pourrait dire que l'île
de france est très urbaine malgré tout
il y à des territoires qu'ils sont
j'appellerai ça plus rurales que en
proximité enclavé dans les grandes zones
d'activités de d'habitation donc des
grandes villes le séminaire vise à
montrer que la qualité de vie dans les
grandes métropoles dépend largement de
la présence autour de territoires
agricoles dynamiques
alors pourquoi l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre pourquoi il faut des terres
agricoles
à côté des des zones urbaines pour que
la qualité de vie soit bonne et
aujourd'hui il me semble que là les
habitants ont besoin de pouvoir s'évader
sans forcément aller très loin et dont
le pouvoir se promener dans une zone
très très naturelle dans des poumons
vers des zones d'activités qui est
vraiment attire bien au delà des
communes avoisinantes qui attire des
gens de paris pour venir se promener et
donc dans une zone d'attraction forte on
peut le lire vous évoquer l'aspect du
paysage il ya des terres agricoles vont
aussi apporter des ressources naturelles
primordial pour la ville je pense à
l'eau au bois d'autres d'autres
ressources mais voilà ça va apporter
aussi ses ressources naturelles
voilà exactement l'agriculture les
territoires non bâti apporte une qualité
de paysages une qualité de vie par
l'environnement
la biodiversité est donc toute cette
faune et flore qui se mélange à la ville
et qui habite correctement si tout le
monde prend soin et attention en nickel
milieu il va évoluer
aujourd'hui on parle urbanisme
construction des fois aussi sur les
terres agricoles pourquoi justement faut
il faut les préserver cet art agricole
il m'apparaît évident de préserver ses
terres agricoles parce que vous
préserver on a besoin de production de
nourriture
on a un besoin de préserver un cadre de
vie l'enjeu de demain il me semble et
l'enjeu alimentaire l'enjeu de l'eau et
sans sens des territoires dits naturels
on ne croit pas répondre à cet enjeu là
j'allais vous êtes également président
des jeunes agriculteurs d'ile-de-france
est ce qu'aujourd'hui l'ile-de-france
570 mille hectares de terres cultivées
est ce que c'est un territoire agricole
dynamique
oui c'était un territoire très dynamique
qui est en pleine évolution en plus
beaucoup de jeunes s'y installent même
si le le défi de l'installation pas
forcément
et une grosse montagne à gravir il y a
plein de volonté et pleins d'initiatives
vraiment intéressantes et innovantes
pour notre agriculture pour mieux
comprendre et cerner les enjeux de ces
territoires aux agresseurs dans des
exemples vont être pris demain au
séminaire sur ce qui se fait ailleurs au
canada à montréal à genève en suisse ou
encore à milan en italie
comment ça se passe là bas est ce que la
dynamique est meilleure qu'en france
alors ça je vais pas pouvoir vous le
dire et je pourrai tellement dire demain
voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on fait participer ses
territoires pour connaître aussi se sent
richir de donner d'autres territoires
qui sont sûrement pas grand chose à voir
avec le nôtre parce que nous il ya une
dimension d'histoire aussi sur la plaine
de versailles
donc bon voilà on va pouvoir faire notre
analyse et en tirer les conclusions pour
savoir comment nous allons avancer avec
les enjeux de demain parce qu'on a un
enjeu sur la grande métropole métropole
grand paris qu'elle va en être de la
gouvernance sur la ruralité
et l'enjeu alimentaire de cette grande
métropole
est ce qu'on va nous donner les moyens
de saisir cette opportunité
ou est ce que la terre agricole va
rester une réserve de terres à bâtir
justement et ses politiques publiques
concernant les territoires urbains il
faut en faire plus aujourd'hui
oui mais pas assez oui tout à fait
aujourd'hui on est la seule région
en ile de france qui dispose d'un
soutien aux territoires aghrib comme ça
c'est la région le conseil régional
d'île de france
ensuite il y à quelques
intercommunalités mais sur les 5
malheureusement elle n'aide pas tout
cette association pour vivre et créer
des projets et ensuite il y à un soutien
aussi du département du conseil
départemental qui reste malgré tout on
en attendre est encore un petit peu plus
pour pouvoir devrait encore mieux sur ce
territoire alors sur le programme de
demain il ya deux tas de grandes tables
rondes qui sont au programme c'est ça
oui ça t'a fait il ya deux grandes
tables rondes avec la première
thématique qui est la politique quelle
politique quelle gouvernance sur un
territoire à gryon bain et la deuxième
comment renforcer la digne la dynamique
de ces territoires et on l'a dit donc
des intervenants qui viennent de
l'étranger il y aura une diversité
d'acteurs aussi bien des élus des
représentants agricoles des exploitants
mais aussi les des chercheurs
universitaires moi la raison de
exactement et des représentants aussi de
tout c'est toutes ces structures conseil
régional conseil départemental et
intercommunalités alors quand on lit le
programme demain son site également la
présence de valérie pécresse présidente
de la région ile de france de stéphane
travert ministre de l'agriculture est ce
qu'ils ont répondu favorablement à votre
invitation
alors le ministre n'ont n'a pas pu
répondre favorablement et
valérie pécresse sera représenté par sa
vice présidente alexandra dublanche
dernière question qu'est ce qui ferait
que ce soit une réussite qu'est ce que
vous attendez demain de ce séminaire il
faut pouvoir en sortir des conclusions
et construire un projet autour de ces
territoires qui à mon sens ont toute
leur place pour préserver notre région
et apporter un service aussi à la
société civile
par le biais de l'alimentation et
d'autres services encore indirecte par
le biais de l'environnement la
biodiversité les l'enjeu de l'eau donc
voilà c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant
pour tout le monde merci alexandre rey
d'avoir états et président des jeunes
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france exploitants
à bailly est membre de l'association
patrimoniale de la plaine de versailles
et du plateau d à lui et à qui organise
ce séminaire je le rappelle les
territoires agréés urbain facteur
d'attractivité des grandes métropoles
c'est demain mercredi de 9 heures à 13
heures au domaine de grand'maisons à
villepreux et pour plus d'informations
sur cet événement vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet de la plaine
de versailles
c'est votre rendez-vous tous les mardis
dans le 7-8 journal le portrait de la
semaine ce soir nous vous emmenons dans
les cuisines d'un jeune chef versaillais
à seulement 24 ans romain lucas et
gérante son établissement
il propose une cuisine semi
gastronomique et mise sur la qualité de
ses produits découverte avec au rayon ce
[Musique]
heiva écoute je vais prendre gestion des
baies langoustines
il est 8h30 au marché notre dame de
versailles romain lucas vient ici
plusieurs fois dans la semaine pour
étoffer la carte de son restaurant
ce qui retient particulièrement son
attention des produits frais et locaux
je vais prendre cette tradition
super passage obligé ensuite chez un
maraîcher bio choux épinards ou encore
comme couette que le jeune chef
cuisinera dans quelques instants
ce parti après le chargement effectué
direction le restaurant nuances à
quelques centaines de mètres du marché
un établissement que romain lucas
connaît bien puisqu'il y était en
apprentissage
après quelques expériences dans les
yvelines et à paris il décide il y a
huit mois d'acheter ce restaurant un
projet qui a un peu effrayé son
entourage malgré tout toujours présent à
ses côtés de lénine comme pour les
papiers organisée on va dire on veut des
paquets pour le linge tout les dessous
du restaurant
il est 10 heures romain est en cuisine
des gestes précis qui lui ont notamment
été transmis par sa grand mère on a très
bien manger à moi et ma soeur et anti
donc on va nous préparer des très bons
plats c'est vrai que sans forcément
participer tout le temps mais en rien
qu'en la regardant
à voir le restaurant propose une carte
simple mais qui change toutes les deux
semaines quatre entrées quatre plats
quatre desserts tout est élaboré dans
cette cuisine midi le service commence
le jeune chef cuisinier s'occupe des
plats chauds au menu ce midi noix de
veau accompagné de son écrasé de pommes
de terre et de sa sauce moutarde
je trouve qu'une différence entre le
restaurateur et le cuisinier alors un
cuisinier va prendre le temps pour sa
cuisine il va transmettre quelque chose
dans l'assiette d'un restaurateur tu vas
pas forcément faire du frais voilà
nourrit des personnes voilà moi pas
forcément l'objet piégeux je nourris
mais mais également voilà je transmets
quelque chose j'ai envie de transmettre
mon métier et ma passion dans mes
assiettes
romain n'officie pas seul dans son
restaurant il est assisté de thomas en
cuisine et de cédric pour le service en
salle bien à garonor un patron
compréhensif et qui est prêt à laisser
sa chance à n'importe qui mais vraiment
c'est quelqu'un un jeune chef cuisinier
qui vous l'aurez compris mise avant tout
sur la qualité des produits présents
dans les assiettes et qui met tout en
oeuvre pour réveiller vos papilles
gustatives et ça donne faim un peu de
culture à présent la pièce a été créée
par jean louis à barreaux en 1968 est
proposé à l'époque à l'elysée montmartre
depuis rabelais n'a plus été rejouée
cinquante ans plus tard la pièce renaît
au théâtre montansier à versailles ce
spectacle fou de 2h30 traverse les cinq
oeuvres de rabelais dont pantagruel et
gargantua six représentations sont
programmées jusqu'à dimanche à
versailles ça commence ce soir à 20h30
et mise en scène signée hervé van der
molen mélanie poker et quentin le frère
le rencontrer avec van der molen bonjour
alors vous êtes le premier à faire
rejouer rabelais de jean louis barrault
pourquoi cette oeuvre qui a cette année
50 ans bah c'est pas du tout
pour commémorer les 50 ans de mai-68
puisqu'il avait créé sa juste après mai
68 dont simplement je suis tombé sur
cette adaptation il ya un peu plus d'un
an et j'ai eu un vrai coup de foudre
parce que je trouve qu'il a su qu'on
danse et non pas toute l'oeuvre de
rabelais mais en tout cas un parcours à
travers toute l'oeuvre de rabelais du
début à la fin d'une façon formidable
et puis comme avec notre compagnie
asnières et notamment dans le cadre du
projet qu'on fait chaque année avec
versailles
je cherche toujours un vrai spectacle de
troupes là je me suis dit il ya vraiment
matière à faire quelque chose de ce côté
là d'importants d'original
d'autant plus qu'il a non seulement le
texte de rabelais mais il ya beaucoup de
musique beaucoup de chants et puis
barreau aussi raconte non seulement
l'histoire des personnages de rabelais
mais aussi fait un parallèle avec
l'espoir du xvième siècle et un
parallèle avec notre histoire
contemporaine
donc je me suis dit que là il y avait
matière à faire un travail formidable
voilà très long puisqu'on y est depuis
le 15 octobre
la première est de 6 mars
mais voilà on j'espère qu'on a rempli
contraint un spectacle de troupeaux
vallée dit ils sont 19 sur cinq 19
comédiens
c'est peut-être compliqué à mettre en
scène une fille ils ont plusieurs rôles
certains oui c'est compliqué bon ceci
dit ça se fait de plus en plus rarement
c'est vrai qu'en barreau a créé le
spectacle ils étaient 30 vous imaginez
c'est impossible aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui il y en a 19 qui est
déjà énorme
effectivement il ya un gros gros boulot
de coordination est aussi un gros boulot
de chorégraphier de musique mais je suis
pas tout seul il ya un chorégraphe jean
marc ribette avec moi un compositeur
marc olivier dupin des chefs de chant et
puis il ya une importante partie très
importante de la scénographie claire
belloc et costumes d'isabelle pas ce qui
est des lumières de stéphane deschamps
on a l'habitude de travailler ensemble
depuis plusieurs années on a fait le
spectacle avec la compagnie répond que
des français d'ailleurs et on a
construit tout ça ensemble voilà mais il
fallait ça il fallait l'énergie aussi
des dix neuf comédiens l'énergie vous
dites la pièce dure 2 heures 45 à peu
près à un rythme fou ça ne s'arrête
jamais peu de pauses peu de respiration
oui c'est ça c'est deux heures- 50 avec
l'entracte quelque chose comme ça du
temps de ben arous ça devait bien duré
quatre heures parce que je peux vous
dire que j'en ai coupé beaucoup
mais avait aussi beaucoup de références
historiques on comprenait plus mais ça
demande une énergie tout le temps mais
ceci dit je il ménage aussi quelques
passages plus plus calme plus serein
pour un peu écouté aussi la parole
philosophique de rabelais il n'y a pas
seulement la fête tout ce qu'on connaît
autour du vin de la boisson tout ce qui
est aussi absolument énorme dans la
caricature dans tout ça mais il ya aussi
des pages très belle poétique et
philosophique ils font comme des pauses
au milieu de tout ça et j'ai essayé de
respecter cet équilibre-là voilà et vos
comédiens ne sont pas que comédien
voulant demander de chanter de danser
vous avez cités ceux qui vous ont aidé à
monter cette pièce c'est un tout oui
absolument
l'idée c'est tellement de partir de la
troupe donc le compositeur a écrit à
partir de leurs voix en tout cas pour
les coeurs je peux vous dire qu'ils en
ont bavé parce que pardon il ya quand
même des choeurs de la renaissance à six
ou sept voix c'est pas facile quand on
n'a pas l'habitude et puis on est parti
des forces musical de la troupe c'est à
dire y avait quand même deux pianistes
trois flûtistes une trompettiste deux
guitaristes et ya un comédien qui s'est
mis à la percu et voilà on est parti de
là au niveau de la mise en scène vous
utilisez aussi beaucoup le théâtre
montansier fait partie intégrante de la
pièce c'est important d'utiliser cet
espace oui alors on peut pas l'utiliser
au point on l'utilisé baron parce que
barreau qui s'était fait virer de
l'odéon mai 68 a créé ce spectacle à la
rentrée après à l'elysée montmartre qui
était à
une salle de catch donc ça se passait
avec des spectateurs tout autour sur un
ring de catch et il y avait énormément
de choses dans le rapport au public donc
dans la mesure du possible on a essayé
de le recréer ici aussi autres au
théâtre montansier voilà merci à hervé
van der molen alors rabelais est à
découvrir au théâtre montansier jusqu'au
dimanche 11 mars avant de se quitter une
performance de lecture et
d'improvisation musicale elle était
organisée ce dimanche à la commanderie
des templiers d'elancourt la
représentation à clôturer l'exposition
perception et illusion un spectacle
surprenant auxquelles n'ont pu assister
michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
dandois une ambiance rouge un solo de
guitare des textes évoquant le chaos
inspiré d'une série de photos prises par
richard dumas en 1994 au matin de
l'incendié du parlement de bretagne
les deux artistes olivier mellano et
richard dumas ont créé une improvisation
musicale abstraite ou les écrits sur les
seules matières de l'oeuvre on connaît
les éléments qui en ces cas le texte ces
bouts de textes mais richard pour les
prendre n'importe quel moment et on est
vraiment on écoute l'un et l'autre est
en réaction par rapport à ce qui se
passe à ce moment là donc on fait on n'a
jamais fait deux fois pareil c'est la
première fois que cette manière qu avec
la guitare concédions fonce et puis on
verra
ça se passe il faut sentir le moment
telles paroles raisonnée pour entrer en
résonance en allemagne ou en résonance
pour leur troisième représentation
devant un public les artistes ont voulu
également adapté en temps réel cette
improvisation face aux réactions de la
salle on prend l'ensemble des gens qui
sont là on sait ce qui qui voilà qui est
là et on n'est pas qu'on n'est pas coupé
de ces gens n'ont pas coupé des gens que
nous sommes se forme un tout une recette
qui a fonctionné auprès de la
quarantaine de spectateurs présents à la
commanderie des templiers
c'était une performance
mais ici au niveau contemplatif j avale
s'amène les mots l'essence
[Musique]
la musique et le sens des mots moi je
pars moment j'entendais pas tout mais
des mots comme ça qui surgissaient comme
dans un rêve parfois comme dans un
cauchemar
le rendez-vous à clôturer l'exposition
perception et illusions installé pendant
quatre mois et long cours le public lui
en redemande
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition le
7-8 journal et ses reportages sont à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]